للمزيد من التفاصيل حول هذه القضيه معنا
الان من واشنطن مراسله الجزيره محمد
العلمي محمد اهلا بك اذا هل تكشف المزيد
لن يتكشف المزيد سفيان حتى لو مثل المتهم
امام القضاء لان هذا هذه النوعيه من
المحاكم او المحاكمات
تعمل الحكومه على ان تتم في سريه تامه
حفاظا على سريه الوثائق التي يعرفها معظم
سكان العالم الان لكن الحكومه الامريكيه
تستعد
معارك متعدده على جبهات مختلفه اولا على
مستوى المحكمه نفسها كما قلت الحكومه لا
تريد محاكمه علنيه لانه يتعين عليها ان
تكشف النقاب عن الوثائق وربما المزيد من
الوثائق وربما ستكون الرغبه في الوصول الى
صفقه مع المتهم عبر محاميه من اجل عقوبه
مخففه نسبيا وان كان من المنتظر انه سيقضي
سنوات طوال من عمره وراء او داخل السجون
الفيدراليه ثانيا معرفه ماذا يملك ماذا
يعرف اكثر هل كان مدفوعا بدفع سياسي او
مالي او اخلاقي او غير ذلك مما دفعه الى
فعل ما تم وربما الاكبر من ذلك سفيان هو
ما اشار اليه وزير الدفاع الامريكي في
بيان صدر قبل قليل فقط
ويشير الى ضروره اعاده النظر عن الحكومه
الامريكيه تعيد النظر في من يحق له
الاطلاع على بعض الوثائق دون غيرها لان
فسح المجال امام عشرات الالاف من العيون
حتى العيون التي لا يهمها الموضوع اساسا
كما حدث مع هذا الشاب يطلع على تقييم
المخابرات الامريكيه
لمواطن الضعف والقوه في الجيش الاوكراني
وهو هذا لا يهمه وليس من اختصاصه المهني
عضو في فريق الحرس القومي في احدى ولايه
الشمال الشرقيه المتحده واخيرا هناك جبهه
التح ديات الدبلوماسيه لمحاوله اقناع
الحلفاء الذين اثبتت الوثائق انا تجسس
عليهم انها لم تكن تعني ذلك او انهم
يتجسسون عليها مقابل ذلك او غير ذلك من
محاوله تلطيف الاجواء لكن هناك بعض
المعلومات تسربت ولا مجال للسيطره على
تداعياتها شكرا لكم محمد العالمي كنت معنا
من واشنطن